I'm just shocked at how many people Vape
first of all not unlike cigarette
smoking it's expensive it's clearly
addictive it's clearly detrimental to
lung function people like how it makes
their brain feel and they think that if
they're already Physically Active then
they can offset some of that in the next
5 years or so we're just going to see a
slew of studies showing that vaping is
just bad for us especially for the
developing brain because it's bringing
in at a very rapid rate high potency
nicotine and high potency cannabis the
slope of that increase in dopamine and
epinephrine adrenaline and acetylcholine
is so important the sharper that slope
the faster the rise the more addictive
potential these compounds have I
understand maybe of the two evils vaping
is less of an evil than traditional
smoking would be but I think the
enjoyability the accessibility the fact
that it isn't as stigmatized more people
are now going to vape than ever
previously smoked even if the difference
between the two is that vaping is better
that the total area under the curve of
Public Health degradation we've netted a
loss overall for vaping